>> ALL RIGHT.
THIS WILL BE A SIGHT FOR JUST
WEARY EYES OVER THE SKIES OF
BALTIMORE AND WASHINGTON D.C.,
LATER TODAY ATLANTA, GEORGIA.
WE’RE SEEING THE BLUE ANGELS AND
THE THUNDERBIRDS STRUT THEIR
STUFF.
THIS IS JUST SO STUNNING TO ME,
HOW MAJESTIC AND IMPECCABLEY
TIMED, AND THE NEXT GUEST DOES.
THUNDER OPERATIONS, A PILOT
HIMSELF, DON’T MESS WITH THE
COLONEL.
COLONEL, THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
>> THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME ON
THE SHOW.
NEIL: IT’S A WONDERFUL IDEA AND
IT COMES AT A TIME WHEN SO MANY
IN THE NATION NEED IT.
THEY CAN LOOK UP AND JUST BE
AWESTRUCK.
I KNOW I AM, BUT THIS HAS GOT TO
TAKE A LOT OF PRACTICE, RIGHT TO
GET IT SO RIGHT, DOWN TO THE
SECOND, DOWN TO THE INCHES?
>> YEAH, THAT’S CORRECT.
IT’S COMMON FOR THEM TO BE OUT
AND ABOUT IN THE COMMUNITY AND
OFTEN GET TOLD THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE AND NOW ON ABOVE OF
OVER THE SERVICE MEMBERS, EXTEND
OUR GRATITUDE TO THE FRONT LINE
WORKERS.
YOU’RE SEEING A COMBINATION OF
12 EXTREMELY QUALIFIED AND
EXPERIENCED COMBAT FIGHTER AND
VETERAN PILOTS IN THE FORMATIONS
PROVIDING A SALUTE FROM THE
SKIES.
NEIL: YOU KNOW WHAT IS AMAZING
TO ME, COLONEL, WHEN I WATCH IT
IS HOW SO SYNCHRONIZED THIS IS,
YOU CAN’T AFFORD NOT TO BE.
ESPECIALLY AS YOU’RE SEEING IT
FROM A COCKPIT AS YOU ARE NOW,
THE GUYS ARE INCHES APART.
HOW THE HECK DO YOU DO THAT?
>> WELL, NEIL, THAT TAKES
EXTENSIVE TRAINING, EXTREMELY
EXPERIENCED AND QUALIFIED
FIGHTER PILOTS AND PRACTICE
QUITE A BIT.
AND THIS IS OUR BEST WAY TO PASS
OUR MESSAGE OF UNITY AND
STRENGTH AND BRINGING THE WHOLE
COUNTRY TODAY AND SUPPORT
EVERYBODY AND LET THEM KNOW WE
FLY TOGETHER, WE FLY AS ONE AND
BRINGING THE AIR FORCE AND NAVY
TOGETHER IS A SPECIAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO PASS THAT
MESSAGE OF COULD HE HESS --
COHESIVENESS AND WE’RE GOING TO
LOOK OUT FOR EACH OTHER.
NEIL: EACH CLAIMS THEY HAVE THE
BETTER SQUAD, THE AIR FORCE AND
NAVY.
THEY’RE BOTH STUNNING TO ME AND
THEY HAVE TO COORDINATE THIS
WITH EACH OTHER, SO, HOW DO THEY
DO THIS AHEAD OF TIME AND
PRACTICE AHEAD OF TIME?
WHERE THE HECK DO THEY DO IT?
>> SO, WE’VE BEEN DOWN TO
PENSACOLA, FLORIDA WITH THE NAVY
BLUE ANGELS AND HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PRACTICE A FEW
DAYS TO MAKE SURE WE GET THIS
RIGHT AND LOOK VERY PRECISE AND
PERFECT OVER TOP THE COMMUNITIES
STRUGGLING WITH COVID BECAUSE WE
WANT TO SHOW THEM WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER AND WE HAVE YOUR BACKS
AND IT’S REALLY THE BEST TO PASS
OUR MESSAGE OF UNITY TO BRING
THE AIR FORCE AND NAVY.
AND HAVE A LITTLE FRIENDLY
COMPETITION, BUT IN TIMES LIKE
THIS IT’S ABOUT BRINGING
EVERYBODY TOGETHER AND LOVE TO
REPRESENT THE SERVICE AND EXTEND
OUR GRATITUDE TO THE FOLKS ON
THE GROUND BATTLING COVID EVERY
DAY.
THE FRONTLINE WORKERS ARE
WORKING HARD AND WE’RE WORKING
HARD AND WE’RE READY AT ALL
TIMES AND WE SUPPORT THEM.
NEIL: JUST AMAZING.
COLONEL, YOU’RE NO SLOUCH IN
YOUR DEPARTMENT.
BUT WHEN HEROES RECOGNIZE HEROES
IT TAKES ON ADDED SIGNIFICANCE.
COLONEL, THANK YOU AGAIN.
NOT ONLY FOR WHAT YOU DO, BUT
THE MESSAGE YOU’RE SENDING TODAY
TO THE HEALTH CARE WORKERS AND